[Musique]
il ya 30 ans l'union soviétique s'est
effondré comment avez vous perçu ces
événements à l'époque j'étais parmi les
partisans de la démocratie la rédaction
du journal russia se trouvait à la
maison blanche nous avons passé deux
nuits inoubliables à la rédaction à la
maison blanche on était au centre de
presse du ministère des affaires
étrangères lors de la célèbre conférence
de presse du comité d'état pour l'état
d'urgence j'ai bien sûr changé plusieurs
fois d'opinion sur ces événements comme
tout le monde s'en doute mais à ce
moment là il y avait bien sûr une sorte
d'euphorie démocratique ips enthousiasme
il est probablement si seulement j'avais
pu imaginer à l'époque en août 91 à quoi
aboutir et ces événements
ce nom se terminerait cet enthousiasme
joyeux dans la lutte contre le monopole
du parti communiste et la censure en
apprenant presse mais personne ne
pensait que cela aboutirait à
l'effondrement d'un grand pays
[Musique]
comme à chaque début d'année olivier
vous nous livrer vos scénarios pour les
365 jours à venir il ya beaucoup de pire
pas beaucoup de bons scénarios précieux
la présidentielle et son impact sur
l'économie il n'y a pas de grande
révolution à attendre fin de grand
changement par rapport à ce qui a été
comme politique on passe au prix de
l'énergie ça plombe la reprise
économique et malheureusement c'est pas
quelque chose qui se qui se règlent en
deux minutes si vous voulez par
l'opération du saint-esprit dernier
règle de la politique monétaire des
banques centrales c'est la banque
centrale qui soutient à bout de bras
tout l'édifice si jamais elle arrête à
ce moment là tout s'écroule comment on
va pouvoir se défaire de ça c'est la
question la plus plus problématique et
on voit bien que on arrive à un moment
où on lâche tout
[Musique]
tous
la fin la peau flo d'ibm en europe grâce
à olic run elle déclaration de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
variant pour est en effet contaminé 60%
des européens d'ici mars d'ici là les
restrictions sur poursuivre des
restrictions une nouvelle fois contesté
cette fois plus saine des heurts entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre ont
éclaté ce dimanche lors de nouvelles
manifestations
nous demandons la fin de ses activités
provocatrices et d'arrêter de 10 des
absurdités moscou hausse le ton après
les dernières accusations du royaume uni
la russie londres accuse moscou de
chercher à installer chez un dirigeant
pro russe à kiev ainsi à qu'à occuper
l'ukraine les etats-unis se disent
préoccupés par ces déclarations cette
passe d'armes intervient alors que les
ministres de la défense russe et
britannique ont annoncé une rencontre à
venir dans les prochains
[Musique]
changer l'atmosphère guerrière situation
pacifique c'est l'objectif des
pourparlers qui ont commencé ce dimanche
à oslo entre talibans et les membres de
la société civile afghane la question
des droits humains et la crise
humanitaire devrait être au coeur des
débats à des entretiens sont aussi
prévues avec des diplomates occidentaux
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue si vous ne retrouvez
sur rtl france défendre la démocratie
les droits de l'homme et le respect de
la constitution ce sont les principales
revendications à des organisateurs de
cette manifestation qui s'est tenue à
bruxelles ce dimanche cinquante mille
personnes venues des quatre coins
d'europe ayant participé à la
manifestation pour protester contre les
restrictions sanitaires elle a donné
lieu à des heurts entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre d'ailleurs qui a
témoigne des tensions parmi la
population car en belgique face à la
propagation de microbes le rappel
vaccinal est désormais obligatoire pour
les adultes pour accéder aux bars et
restaurants notamment et précision de
notre envoyé spécial à bruxelles guy
marosi
le rassemblement a tourné court en
milieu d'après midi il ne restait plus
que quelques milliers de personnes
réunies dans ce parc du cinquantenaire
où je me trouve actuellement le reste a
été dispersé manu militari par des
forces de l'ordre pléthorique à l'aide
de très nombreux tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes et de canons à eau on a
également pu assister à quelques
arrestations de ceux qui refusaient
encore de vider les lieux les
échauffourées elles ont débuté très vite
après l'arrivée du cortège on s'y
attendait un peu vu l'ampleur de la
manifestation les organisateurs
tablaient sur cent mille personnes le
pari semble avoir été tenu des
manifestants venus de toute l'europe à
l'appel du collectif european society
for freedom et de centaines d'autres
organisations on pouvait voir des
drapeaux belges italiens polonais
allemands néerlandais et français aussi
puisque les gilet jaune hexagonaux ont
fait le déplacement notamment depuis le
nord et l'est de la france et je vous
propose d'écouter certains de ces
manifestants présents aujourd'hui moi je
magro le vaccin je suis contre ce
certificat compte ce qrcode je peux pas
le voir sauf que c'est inhumain et on
voit qu'on pourra insérer peut-être
plusieurs choses dedans après par
exemple si tu payes pas des amants du
bepa des impôts tu es un mauvais citoyen
tu pourras dire tu feras plus dans
certains endroits je pense que c'est on
le sent quand on est oppressé et on est
tous là pour le même but pour la liberté
mon sentiment c'est que c'est déjà
merveilleux parce que on se retrouve
tous ensemble ici et pas derrière nos
écrans en train de partager
virtuellement ici c'est la présence et
cela on va on va bien se nourrir tout le
monde ensemble voilà et je pense c'est
ça qui craignent le plus c'est qu'on se
munissent réunissent c'est très
important de savoir ce qu'ils font ce
qu'il faut absolument jamais faire
toucher à notre adn il faut jamais se
faire piquer sur mon corps c'est mon
temple et a personne qui va envahir mon
temple objectif de cette mobilisation
bruxelloise donc de ce dimanche mettre
la pression sur les autorités
européennes afin d'infléchir les
politiques sanitaires appli qui à
travers le continent ce rassemblement
s'est d'ailleurs tenue à quelques
centaines de mètres de la commission
européenne un rassemblement bruxellois
donc qui comme les semaines précédentes
s'est conclue par des affrontements
entre manifestants et forces de l'ordre
si la pandémie ducobu 19 touchait à sa
fin en tout cas c'est ce qu'a laissé
entendre
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ce
dimanche le variant omicron qui
pourraient contaminer 60% des européens
d'ici au mois de mars se rapprocherait
le continent d'une fin de pandémie une
perspective optimiste mais l' oms
rappelle dans le même temps qu'il faut
être prudent au vu de la grande
versatilité sido mikron on écoute le
directeur à régional pour l'europe de
l'oms
il est plausible que la région se dirige
vers une sorte de fin de pandémie non
pas une fin du coc vie de 19 mai une fin
de pandémie
une fois que la vague omicron se sera
calmé il y aura pendant quelques
semaines et quelques mois une immunité
global soit grâce au vaccin soit parce
que les gens seront immunisés en raison
de l'infection est aussi une baisse en
raison de la saisonnalité
nous prévoyons donc une période de calme
avant peut-être le retour du coc vite 19
vers la fin de l'année mais pas
nécessairement le retour de la pandémie
[Musique]
un espoir donc qui coïncide avec
l'entrée en vigueur demain du pass
vaccinale en france il faudra désormais
présenter un schéma vaccinal complet
pour accéder à certains lieux
accueillant du public toutes les
personnes âgées de plus de 16 ans sont
concernés les détails avec sa mère à
chablis
dès ce lundi le pass vaccinale sera
indispensable pour accéder aux lieux de
restauration de divertissement au salon
aux transports inter régionaux et aux
voyages en avion ou encore aux grands
centres commerciaux sur décision des
préfets pour obtenir le sésame il faudra
être vaccinés contre le coc vie de 19 et
avoir reçu au moins deux doses à sept
mois d'intervalle pour les vaccins et si
tu en as rappelle un délai raccourci à
quatre mois après la dernière injection
à partir du 15 février une mesure pour
permettre un allègement des restrictions
selon l'exécutif
la transformation du pass sanitaire en
passe vaccinale est une évolution
nécessaire et cohérente elle est
cohérente car elle assume de faire peser
clairement la contrainte sur les non
vaccinés et dès lors de pouvoir lever
les mesures de freinage que nous avons
prises pour contrer la dernière vague
l'arrivée du pass vaccinale permettra
aussi probablement d'assouplir un
certain nombre de mesures parce que
c'est un outil nouveau dont nous
disposons qui permet de renforcer la
sécurité dans un certain nombre de lieux
seuls les meetings politiques et chapeau
parce vaccinale une mesure initialement
inscrite dans le projet de loi mais
retoqué par le conseil constitutionnel
la loi prévoit également un durcissement
de la lutte contre la fraude les
restaurants et les débits de boisson
pourront par exemple demander une pièce
d'identité en cas de doute sur
l'authenticité du titre
les professionnels du secteur ne cachent
pas leur appréhension à l'instar de ce
restaurateur c'est pas c'est pas naturel
chez nous de le faire comprendre ou bien
donc ça va se faire de façon extrêmement
rare ça veut pas dire qu'on est contre
le passé c'est le passé n'oublions pas
qu'on ait un million de a travaillé dans
la restauration
et il ya 400 milles qui sont à l'accueil
vous rendez compte qu'elles sont mines
personnes l'action donne des pouvoirs
extraordinaires
le pass vaccinale continue d'être
contestée par une partie de la
population comme ce samedi à paris où se
sont rassemblées près de 5200
manifestants d'après le ministère de
l'intérieur trente six mille 500 selon
les organisateurs
un outil qui serait approuvée par 62%
des français selon un sondage au doxa
pour le figaro
en arménie le président arménien
sarkissian a annoncé sa démission après
quatre années au pouvoir dans un
communiqué le dirigeant arménien
explique qu'il n'a pas les outils
nécessaires pour influer sur la vie
politique de son pays armen sarkissian a
été au coeur d'une crise politique qui a
éclaté à la suite de la défaite en 2020
de l'arménie dans une guerre pour le
contrôle de la région contestée du haut
karabagh avec son voisin et rival de
longue date l'azerbaïdjan
un focus sur la crise en ukraine londres
accusent désormais moscou de chercher à
installer un dirigeant pro russe à kiev
la russie dénonce des absurdités à ces
accusations arrive alors que les
ministres de la défense russe et
britannique ont prévu une rencontre à
venir dans les prochains jours et
précision de notre correspondant à
moscou antoine claireaux
tout a commencé avec un communiqué de la
secrétaire d'état britannique dans
lequel elle dénonce l'ampleur de
l'activité russe à ses frontières qui a
selon elle pour but de déstabiliser
ukraine elles prêtent ensuite que moscou
a pour objectif d'installer un dirigeant
pro russe à kiev nous possédons des
informations qui indiquent que le
gouvernement russe cherche à installer
un dirigeant pro russe à kiev au moment
où il envisage d'envahir et d'occuper
l'ukraine l'ancien député ukrainien
evgeny moore ayem est considéré comme un
candidat potentiel
nous sommes en possession d'informations
selon lesquelles les services de
renseignement russes entretiennent des
liens avec de nombreux anciens hommes
politiques ukrainiens la réponse du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
n'a pas tardé dans un communiqué la
diplomatie russe a demandé aux
britanniques de mettre fin je cite à
leurs activités provocatrices et
d'arrêter de diffuser des absurdités la
désinformation diffusé par le ministère
britannique des affaires étrangères est
une preuve supplémentaire que ce sont
les pays de l'otan dirigée par les anglo
saxons qui aggrave les tensions autour
de l'ukraine nous demandons instamment
au ministère britannique des affaires
étrangères de mettre fin à ses activités
provocatrices d'arrêter de diffuser des
absurdités et de se concentrer sur
l'étude de l'histoire du joug du qatar
même si les relations sont mauvaises
entre moscou et londres allié de premier
plan de washington le dialogue a
cependant le mérite d'exister dans une
réponse à la lettre du secrétaire d'état
à la défense britannique
le ministre russe de la défense s'est
dit prêt à discuter avec lui de tous les
sujets brûlants de l'actualité dont
l'ukraine et la convier à moscou à la
date qui lui conviendra
autre démission celle du chef de la
marine allemande après des critiques sur
certains de ses propos pendant une
réunion en 1/2 l'amiral key achim
shuback a qualifié d' ineptie les
intentions prêtées à la russie par
l'otan et ses alliés d'envahir le cren
est des déclarations qui l'ont conduit à
s'expliquer auprès de sa hiérarchie au
ministère allemand de la défense et
avant de présenter sa démission
aujourd'hui des missions qui a fait
réagir maximilian cra membres du
parlement européen
il ya une ambiance dans le parlement où
chacun veut imposer des sanctions plus
sévères contre la russie et où ils se
préparent au moins verbalement pour une
guerre
il ya un vrai militaire estimant que
c'est une absurdité bien sûr ils sont
très en colère contre lui parce qu'il
fait penser à tout le monde que cette
atmosphère de sentiments antirusses et
de bellicisme n'a rien à voir avec de
véritables menaces de sécurité
c'est juste une politique folle et
diabolique
[Musique]
discussions cruciales à oslo en norvège
les talibans vont rencontrer si des
puissances occidentales ce matin des
échanges ont eu lieu avec des membres de
la société civile afghane un déplacement
inédit depuis leur prise de parole et le
retrait des troupes américaines sur fond
de crise humanitaire et de droits des
femmes il s'agit de renouer le dialogue
à maillas ou blé
c'est le premier voyage du gouvernement
des talibans vers les terres européennes
depuis leur retour au pouvoir ce samedi
14 ministres afghans ont pris l'avion
direction oslo en norvège pour
rencontrer les puissances occidentales
et discuter d'une situation humanitaire
qui se dégrade au fil des semaines à la
tête du pays depuis le mois d'août
dernier les taliban espère une
amélioration des relations avec la
communauté internationale qui refuse
toujours de reconnaître leur
gouvernement
[Musique]
l'émirat islamique a pris des mesures
pour satisfaire les exigences du monde
occidental et nous espérons renforcer
nos relations diplomatiques avec tous
les pays y compris les pays européens et
l'occident en général et changer
l'atmosphère guerrière que nous avions
auparavant en une situation pacifique
le gouvernement taliban n'a toujours pas
tenu certains engagements promis lors de
son accession au pouvoir notamment ce
qui concerne le droit des femmes il y a
quelques jours plusieurs manifester dans
la rue
et aurait été arrêté par les autorités
une accusation réfutée par le porte
parole du gouvernement qui souligne
plutôt les efforts mis en place pour
améliorer et moderniser les lois malgré
tout la situation humanitaire alarmante
compliquer les relations avec l'occident
dont la priorité reste la sécurité de la
population afghane nous sommes
extrêmement préoccupés par la situation
humanitaire grave en afghanistan où des
millions de personnes font face un
désastre humanitaire de grande ampleur
afin de pouvoir aider la population
civile en afghanistan il est essentiel
que tant la communauté internationale
que des afghans de différentes facettes
de la société engage un dialogue avec
les talibans il faut dire que depuis
plusieurs mois l'aide internationale qui
représentait 80% du budget du pays a été
suspendue dans la tente du respect des
droits humains
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié de la
population souffrent de famine selon
l'onu le chômage a augmenté de manière
inédite et de nombreux employés ne sont
plus rémunérés malgré tout le
gouvernement taliban affirme sa volonté
d'apaiser les relations diplomatiques à
l'occasion de leur déplacement en
norvège les nouveaux maîtres de
l'afghanistan rencontreront également
des membres de la société civile de leur
pays parmi lesquelles des journalistes
et des militantes féministes
une visite qui devrait s'achever le 25
janvier est largement contestée par le
front national de résistance
principal groupe d'opposition à l'émirat
islamique lequel il voit la banalisation
d'un groupe terroriste
nouvelles tensions au burkina faso des
soldats ont fait feu dans leurs casernes
ce matin avant de réclamer au
gouvernement plus de moyens dans la
lutte contre les djihadistes plus tard
dans la journée des partisans des
militaires mutins ont incendié le siège
du parti au pouvoir à ouagadougou avant
d'être dispersés par la police le
gouvernement dément toute tentative de
coup d'état françois xavier lambert
des tirs nourris d'armé automatique
résonnent dans la capitale du burkina
faso ils proviennent de trois casernes
abritant des soldats de l'armée
nationale
après ces rafales le calme revient à
ouagadougou mais les rumeurs de coup
d'état commence à se propager rapidement
le gouvernement communique à la
télévision et dément toute prise de
pouvoir par l'armée et chef de l'état
n'a pas été arrêté il n'est aucune
institution de la république l'a été
pour le moins inquiété
cette situation
est pour le moment en train d'être suivi
par nous pour que nous puissions
connaître les motivations réelles des
sept-îles qui sont entendus dans la
foulée un communiqué confiant qu'il
s'agit d'un avertissement de certains
militaires au gouvernement ces soldats
accuse le pouvoir de ne pas faire assez
face aux jihadistes nous voulons des
moyens adaptés à la lutte anti
jihadistes et des effectifs conséquents
ainsi que le remplacement des plus hauts
gradés de l'armée nationale après
l'annnonce de cette mutinerie des
centaines de manifestants se rassemblent
dans plusieurs endroits de la capitale
pour soutenir l'armée des rassemblements
qui dégénère autour du siège du parti au
pouvoir le bâtiment du mouvement du
peuple pour le progrès est en partie
incendié la police qui doit aussi
dispersé une autre manifestation de
soutien aux militaires
pour ces burkinabè le gouvernement doit
laisser le pouvoir à l'armée
demers appel de même dans le val de
marne elle est claire ne
démissionnent nous avait un peu plus la
main qu'une bagnole à boulleville avoir
été papier y a plus depuis la clé de
plagiat sont beaucoup donc ça lui qui
peut pas il n'a pas le laisser à tous
ces incidents soulignent les tensions
persistantes dans le pays samedi des
centaines de personnes ont défilé à
ouagadougou pour dénoncer l'incapacité
des autorités à lutter contre le
terrorisme
le burkina faso comme le niger et le
mali et la cible des groupes djihadistes
depuis plusieurs années une menace aux
conséquences dramatiques sur le plan
humanitaire
auprès de sept ans ces violences
auraient fait plus de 2000 morts et
contrat au million et demi de personnes
à fuir leurs habitations
au mali un nouveau militaire français a
perdu la vie après une attaque au
mortier contre le camp militaire de gao
alexandre martin et le 3 53e militaire
français tué au combat au sahel depuis
2013 ce drame intervient dans un
contexte de fortes tensions entre la
france et le mali théo combes il avait
24 ans et servait au mali depuis le 19
octobre dernier le brigadier alexandre
martin du 54e régiment d'artillerie
d'hyères est décédé après l'attaqué au
mortier de sa garnison à gao à l'est du
pays une attaque qui n'a toujours pas
été revendiqué mais qui survient dans
une zone où des djihadistes affiliés à
al qaïda sont toujours actifs
c'est le 53e militaires français à
perdre la vie au combat au mali depuis
2013 emmanuel macron a tenu à lui rendre
hommage dans un communiqué publié par
l'elysée
emmanuel macron salue avec respect la
mémoire de ceux soldats morts pour la
france dans l'accomplissement de sa
mission il s'associe à la douleur de sa
famille de ses proches et de ses frères
d'armes il les assure de la
reconnaissance et de la solidarité de la
nation le président de la république
salue le courage des militaires engagés
au sel et leur exprime sa totale
confiance si les assaillants ont été
neutralisés selon le porte parole du
chef d'état-major neuf blessés légers
sont à déplorer dans ces attaques un
drame qui survient alors que les
tensions sont vives avec le nouveau
pouvoir malien au sujet de la présence
française dans le pays des frictions qui
sont montées d'un cran entre paris et
bamako quand la junte a été accusé ces
dernières semaines d'avoir fait appel au
groupe paramilitaire russe wagner une
information démentie par les autorités
maliennes depuis quelques mois paris
cherche à réduire sa présence militaire
au sahel de 5000 hommes à l'été 2000 21
elle devrait être ramené entre 3500 et
4000 soldats l'été prochain dans le
cadre d'une réorganisation de barkan et
de la montée en puissance de la mission
européenne takouba
jour de vote au sénégal 7 millions
d'électeurs étaient appelés aux urnes
pour élire un maire et conseillers
départementaux
ce scrutin est le premier depuis la
réélection du président macky sall en
février 2019 un scrutin pour jauger le
rapport de forces entre le dirigeant et
ses opposants et cela à moins de deux
ans de l'élection présidentielle robin
pu l
c'est un scrutin local qui pourrait
influencer la politique nationale des
prochaines années
les élections municipales au sénégal
sont très attendus moins d'un an après
les émeutes meurtrières qui ont secoué
le pays pourtant considéré comme un
exemple de la stabilité du continent des
événements dramatiques mais qui ont
redonné espoir à l'opposition largement
battu lors de la présidentielle de 2010
9 qui a permis la réélection de macky
sall pour les observateurs ce scrutin
doit permettre aux figures de
l'opposition de mesurer leurs forces
ces élections même si elles sont locales
ont un caractère national très marquée à
pratiquement deux ans de la prochaine
élection présidentielle
nous avons dans la configuration
politique du sénégal de nouveaux leaders
une certaine opposition qui émergent qui
va utiliser ces élections locales comme
un tremplin on verra à travers les
résultats de ces élections la force ou
les faiblesses de cette opposition
montante de son côté macky sall souhaite
également tester la popularité de sa
coalition gouvernementale au pouvoir
depuis 2012 une victoire du ministre de
la santé abdoulaye diouf sarah dakar
serait un signe fort alors que la plus
grande ville du pays est dirigé par
l'opposition depuis plusieurs années
mais dans les rues de la capitale où la
population reste parfois critique
vis-à-vis du pouvoir en place l'issue
reste incertaine
c'est demain à dakar on a un maire
oppose adultes de l'état que l'état
laisse amer travailler
parce que les villes doivent être gérées
par les maires que saleh l'opposition
politique
l'état à l'obligation de les laisser
travailler convenablement parce que
c'est ça que nous aurons
il n'apportait rien parce que
le tournoi c'est du bluff et la plupart
du temps il faut travailler
ils font beaucoup de projets qui ne
réalise pas alors voilà pourquoi j'ai
dit c'est du bluff au terme d'une
campagne marquée par des heurts très con
mais mineur ces scrutins locaux
apparaissent comme un premier indicateur
de la force des différents candidats
avant les élections législatives prévues
pour le mois de juin et avec comme
objectif final les élections
présidentielles de 2024
ces élections vont permettre à la
majorité présidentielle de mesurer sa
popularité c'est ce que nous explique
ahmad à amadou vii jobard y chercheront
en éthique des relations internationales
on peut dire que ces élections locales
sont des élections de textes afin de
tester pour la majorité présidentielle
parce qu'il s'agit en effet aussi pour
elle de vérifier son ancrage au sein des
collectivités et des localités au
sénégal entre autres dakar qui n'est en
fait qu'ils aient la vie de la plus
importante où se trouve 40% de l'otan la
nationale et avec tout ce qui s'est
passé à mars 2020 dans la sphère sonko
qui a fragilisé la relation sociale au
sénégal et qui a porté une partie
l'opposition a accusé à être en cours
dans gouverneur macky sall je pense que
il ya des élections locales un test
aussi en prévision des élections
législatives dans quelques mois et
surtout de la présidentielle du 24 mai
c'est aussi me semble t'il un test aussi
pour l'opposition dans la mesure où
elles aussi les sens et vérifier sa
force sur le champ politique sénégalais
et surtout pour se positionner là besoin
de savoir quel est le rapport de
confiance que les collectivités
entretiennent avec les forces de
l'opposition
jour de vote au portugal également sous
le coup de mesures de restriction pour
lutter contre la propagation de mikron
quelques trois cent quinze mille
électeurs étaient appelés aux urnes ce
dimanche pour des élections législatives
anticipées
une semaine avant la date officielle des
élections du 30 janvier 2022 un scrutin
dont le premier ministre socialiste
antonio costa est le favori un vote
crucial pour le portugal après le rejet
du budget 2022 par la gauche radicale
afin de décider je cite de l'avenir du
pays chez de choisir ceux qui les
représenteront
je viens d'avoir l'opportunité de
remplir mon devoir civique en votant il
s'est naturellement que je lance un
appel à tous ceux qui se sont inscrits
pour le vote anticipé d'aujourd'hui
qu'ils viennent voter et j'appelle tous
les autres a voté le 30 janvier
moi tout ce que j'espère c'est que le
pays ne vire pas à l'extrême droite
malheureusement je n'ai pas beaucoup
d'espoir pour ces élections l'idéal
serait que quelqu'un puisse avoir une
majorité pour gouverner mais tout
indique qu'il n'y en aura pas on va donc
continuer dans une situation d'impasse
prix
je pense qu'il n'aurait jamais dû avoir
d'élections tout simplement la gauche
aurait dû voter le budget maintenant on
va voir ce que cela va donner mais les
sondages sont serrés on va voir mais il
n'y aurait jamais dû avoir d'élections
la gauche aurait dû s'entendre
j'aimerais bien que la situation
s'améliore si possible mais avec cette
pandémie s'est un peu compliqué vous en
conviendrez on va devoir encore attendre
un peu je pense que
julian assange pourra-t-il faire appel
de son extradition vers les états unis
c'est une question à laquelle doit
répondre ce lundi la cour suprême du
royaume uni en décembre la haute
juridiction britannique avait autorisé
l'extradition du journaliste outre
atlantique il s'agit d'une décision de
la dernière chance pour julian assange
aux etats unis ils encourent il fait
face à des accusations d'espionnage et
encourt une peine de près de 175 ans de
prison
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité ce sera dans une trentaine
de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post
der spiegel
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçus
mais pas surpris
[Musique]
l'afrique acté à la cible de 28 millions
de cyber attaques entre janvier et août
2020 est elle devenue la nouvelle terre
de prédilection des cybercriminels nous
manquons cruellement de compétences
qualifiées en termes de cybersécurité on
estime que 96% des incidents de
cybersécurité ne serez pas elle signalé
on resterait non résolus qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire sur l'action des étals sont à
la fois régulateur mais aussi coupable
de la situation les budgets alloués à la
cyber sécurité en afrique reste très
très très insuffisant 15 pays africains
seulement possède une stratégie
nationale de cybersécurité et ça fait
que ça risque réellement de créer le
chaos dont tout le continent
[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes
semblent s'être octroyé à un pouvoir de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens j'ai
cherché j'ai essayé de trouver des
réponses mais émettra 20 suis jamais à
oger une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question l'a toujours eu un
rôle historique pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio on
sait si c'est grave ou si c'est pas
grave plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission